i
de pequeño era un destructor profesional
sé que suena super extraño así que
déjame darte un ejemplo si tuvieras
llegado a una comida con mi yo de 5 años
lo primero que has hecho era esconder tu
celular tu bolsa lo que fuera porque
llegar a tocarlo de un celular te
entregaba mil y un piezas claves y
cuando estaba muy alegre decía que para
si ese tornillo este secreto que puedas
dígalo esto yo ya parecía un museo de
pieza mi alrededor y tampoco era bueno
construyendo y reconstruyendo algo o si
mañana el colmo de un niño destructor
que no podía construir pedían leguas de
navidad para que alguien más nos
construyera yo poder destruirlos por
completo ver esa estructura caer pedazo
a pedazo me fascinaba todo eso cambió
cuando me dieron la mala noticia y
empecé a odiar las destrucciones mis
papás me sentaron a mis 12 años de
misión y con tu mamá y yo nos vamos a
divorciar la vez que no lo tome para
nada bien lo tomé de la peor manera
posible de verdad me volví súper
amargado quejumbroso simplemente para
que te des una idea de qué tan
quejumbroso era te voy a dar un
recorrido en mi día a día me despertaba
me quejaba del sueño de que a mí me iba
a desayunar y me queja al desayuno y
tienes mi sería el favorito
y me quejaba de la maestra me peleaba
con todos con quien se pusiera enfrente
yo me iba a pelear luego regresaba a la
escuela y me quejaba de cómo me había
quejado de la escuela en la escuela
decía me piten puede haber quejado mucho
mejor me puede haber peleado con esa de
verdad yo vivía amargado pero ahora que
lo veo más fríamente me doy cuenta que
la amargura y sus raíces ya estaban
desde antes del divorcio de mis padres
pero se mostraron la primavera del
diversión mis padres me di cuenta que
las destrucciones muestran esas raíces
que no nos gusten muestran esas cosas
que realmente llevamos cultivando años o
meses en los secretos eso hace las
destrucciones el haber es que vivimos en
un mundo caótico y cosas se destruyen
tristemente me gustaría que hiciéramos
un ejercicio intenso que sea que
destruyen tu vida que te mantiene
estresado estresada que con ansiedad
quejándote más de lo normal tal vez en
amargura al igual que yo voy a darte un
ejemplo y me gustaría que te meterá esta
metáfora aunque es un poco extraña yo
veo como si estuviéramos en un barco y
en este barco es eso que se destruyó en
nuestras vidas puede ser ese matrimonio
puede ser esa relación puede ser ese
trabajo
y nos avientan o nos aventamos en mi
ejemplo el barco era el matrimonio de
mis padres y yo normalmente yo no les
dije a ver los reto que se divorcian
obviamente no a mí me aventaron me
agarraron misión hijo tu mamá y yo nos
vamos a divorciar
pero también tú puedes aventar te puedes
ir a la oficina de tu jefe decirle jefe
usted es un hijo de todo
renuncio
[Música]
y realmente no vengo a hablar de si está
venta no nos aventaron lo que pasó la
verdad es que vengo a hablar del océano
más que nada porque este océano no es
específicamente acapulco no son piñas
coladas bailes y todo y asombroso es un
lugar muy peligroso es un lugar muy
difícil de estar ahí la verdad es que la
miseria abunda en ese momento y en ese
océano las olas y la tormenta nos pega a
diario y nos pide que nos quedemos ahí
la verdad que este océano es muy
deprimente tal vez habíamos estado
acompañados en este barco y nos avientan
y estamos en soledad por después de
tanto tiempo sin estarlo la verdad es
que la miseria y sobra y nos pide que
nos quedemos y es muy raro porque no
queremos estar ahí pero tampoco queremos
movernos no tenemos fuerza para movernos
la vez que tuvieses estás dando una
charla ted seguro tienes la mejor
historia de cómo está lista y luego
luego nada este súper empoderado o algo
por el estilo la verdad es que no
tristemente yo me auge no solamente me
ahogué maugé súper rápido porque me
amarre una piedra el pie y esa piedra
fue el odio es muy curioso el odio
porque es como una cárcel en nuestra
mente yo abrí unas celdas se las prepara
mis padres y les dije punto castigados
perdedores están en la celda
pero luego me di cuenta que la celda
ellos no estaban estaba yo quien hacía
daño odiando los grammy cuando o días
más le haces daño a ellos te haces daño
a ti porque nadie pasa todo el día
pensando en cuanto a los odios pero tú
si estás todo el día pensando en tu odio
hacia ellos el odio es una de esas
piedras que te hunde lentamente más
rápido la vez que te más profundo
llegues hay menos luz la oscuridad es
más fuerte y hay criaturas más
peligrosas
una vez que tres años de mi vida yo
estuve ahogándome lentamente
hubo un tiempo que decía mis pulmones
deben de ser de acero porque sigo vivo
la verdad es que para mí fue muy duro
eso a través de una ayuda espiritual
salí del mar y una vez más vi la luz se
sentía que toda era increíble y disfruté
la vida y veía lo maravilloso que existe
en este mundo y me metí a un barco
corriendo porque me pareció una
excelente idea sales del mar y me meto
un barco corriendo así lo más pronto
posible soy a 15 años y decidí meterme a
las relaciones amorosas que excelente
idea una vez que todo un adolescente
hormonal me la pasé bien unos meses y
edad
una vez más me encontraba en este océano
pero esta vez se veía más triste más
sombrío más oscuro más denso las olas
eran más fuertes y la lluvia pegaba más
la vez que no sabía qué hacer pero dije
no va a pasar otros tres años de mi vida
deprimido voy a nadar
y nada muy roto nadie y es cuando me di
cuenta de algo cuando caemos caemos muy
rotos caemos de lado y nos rompemos un
brazo o una costilla lo que sea y hay un
tiempo de duelo y el tiempo de duelo
tiene de propósito curarnos para nadar
porque nadie nada bien con un brazo roto
pero también hay otra perspectiva esto
puedes empezar a llorar y ahogarte en tu
dolor porque me rompí el brazo y nunca
curarte y ahogarte en esa miseria pero
bueno entonces empiezan a dar con el
brazo en medio roto y tuve que detenerme
para darle el tiempo de vuelo a mi brazo
y empezar a nadar bien y cuando seguirá
dando sentí que me iba a ahogar y cuando
sentía que me estaba ahogando por
completo encontré una joya en medio de
este mar encontré los nuevos normales
estos nuevos normales sé que es muy
extraño decirlo pero y ya que ya estamos
hartos hemos escuchado nuevos normales
como un eslogan de publicidad como una
campaña gubernamental pero creo que hay
una excelente cosa dentro de esta frase
para empezar hay que diferenciar un
nuevo comienzo de un nuevo normal un
nuevo comienzo es como caes al mar tú no
decides estar bien también también como
un choque de carros ya estás ahí hay
unos que los avientan dan tres vueltas
y parecen de las olimpiadas y es
increíble y otros como yo que caemos
estrellados que queremos decir del lado
super rotos por completo la verdad es
que un nuevo comienzo dicta cómo caíste
es un bueno nuevo un mal nuevo comenzó
pero no normal no dice cómo caíste dice
cómo vas a nadar eso es lo increíble el
nuevo normal se tiene que construir es
muy difícil pero se tiene que construir
y tenemos que construir un camino para
salir del mar porque nadie sale del mar
como entró nadie y construirlo es
difícil imagínate yo soy un destructor
profesional en construir algo en mi vida
fue difícil y más porque estás roto y
tienes que hacerlo pieza por pieza un
nuevo normal no promete perfección
porque ya había algunos diciendo yo
tengo un nuevo normal y ya estoy harto o
ya no hay unicornio es 9 que iris no
todo es perfecto la vez que no un nuevo
normal no pero no promete perfección
prometen mejorías un nuevo normal no
dice mira todo es perfecto aquí dice es
mejor que haya ese es el truco de los
nuevos normales es algo asombroso pero
duele mucho poner pieza por pieza
nos empieza a desgarrar poco a poco la
verdad y esto no es una filosofía barata
de nada sonriendo y todo va a estar bien
y vas a salir adelante no muchas veces
tendrá que nadar roto rota por completo
en medio de las nubes y de la tormenta
pero vas a tener que salir porque no hay
otra manera es difícil construir nuevos
normales pero vale la pena un nuevo
normal no dice si le mandas un mensaje a
la chica que te gusta se va a casar
contigo un nuevo normal dice vale la
pena el riesgo de que no la se convierta
en un acepto se trata de construir de
riesgos tal vez un nuevo normal no luce
tan brillante pero es necesario tal vez
es cuidar tu salud mental un poco más
tal vez es vivir la vida más alegre no
sé y tal vez a veces dices qué flojera
pero es la única oportunidad que tenemos
la vez que tome estos dos ejemplos
porque nos podemos identificar una
ruptura amorosa un divorcio pero muchas
veces en mi vida se destruyen cosas
ahorita estoy en época que se me
destruye en cosas y tengo que construir
y vengo roto completamente pero voy a
construir nuevos normales porque si me
avientan de mí
yo construiré mil nuevos normales y ojo
hay dos tipos de barcos hay un barco en
el que también dan y dices wow qué
increíble barco esto es asombroso está
bien está si dices este barco vale la
pena vivir nadar en recuerdo a este
barco y otros barcos que nadan les
tenemos que decir nos vemos luego nos
vemos mejor nunca
tenemos que decidir que queremos
construir también y es doloroso pero
creo mucho en los nuevos normales creo
que para tu vida puede transformar por
completo incluso ahorita que muchas
casas nuestra vida se destruyen hay
nuevos comienzos pero más importantes y
nuevos normales yo te animo a construir
esa es la historia de cómo un niño que
destruye cosas empezó a construir cosas
para ser más específicos nuevos normales